you can just tell from watching donald
trump's rallies this week that there's
something new going on there's a sort of
desperate anger i would call it that
wasn't really there before and it
culminated in humiliating fashion last
night
with donald trump at a rally in erie
pennsylvania which started nearly 50
minutes late for
no particular reason i covered part of
it live donald trump telling the
audience
he doesn't even want to be there but
he's losing now
and he sort of has to be there he
doesn't want to but he had to do it
great way to get the audience on your
side right take a look
because you know before the play came in
i had it made
i wasn't coming to erie i i mean i have
to be honest there's no way i was coming
i didn't have to
i would have called you and said hey
erie you know if you have a chance get
out but we had this thing won
we were so far up we had the greatest
economy ever greatest jobs greatest
everything
and then we got hit with the plague and
i had to go back to work hello erie
may i please have your vote i wouldn't
be here if i didn't have to
because i screwed up the coronavirus
response imagine if barack obama had
ever said that
imagine if joe biden said that during
this election or if hillary
clinton had said that back in 2016 i
really don't want to be here
but i had to come here to this lame
place because i'm losing and by the way
if you don't vote for me i will never
come back which donald trump has been
saying
in pennsylvania and in north carolina
and in many other places and
by the way this idea that
coronavirus had to hurt him that
inevitably
the virus hurt him so now he has to
campaign
world leaders who did a good job with
the virus are cruising to re-election
jacinda ardern in new zealand
sailed to overwhelming re-elections and
a bigger labor majority than i think new
zealand has ever seen
because she handled the coronavirus
properly as i've said before if trump
had handled the virus properly
biden would have no shot right now so
that's also
completely wrong then maybe the most
humiliating moment of this rally
donald trump saying nobody wants him
really i can't believe it
you better give me the credit damn it
i'll tell you what i put
what i've gone through the drug
companies they're spending a fortune on
fake ads
they don't want me they don't want me
china doesn't want me
iran doesn't want me nobody wants
nobody
[Music]
eerie eerie wants me it's easy to write
this stuff
off as merely the rantings of a madman
but i think there is something real here
which is donald trump does see the polls
and even though publicly he says he's
winning he knows he might lose
he does realize that everything he's
doing is sinking him further and further
he does the first debate the polls
collapse uh
uh he continues to crater in many
important states and i think trump is
cognizant of that and that's why you're
seeing
this attitude from donald trump trump
then
still confused about how stealth planes
work trump still seems to think
that stealth planes are invisible to the
naked eye
rather than invisible to enemy radar
terry
we now have the greatest equipment we've
ever had
we are the envy of russia and china and
everybody in the world we have the best
missiles and rockets
and tanks and planes f-35
stealth you can't see it other than that
it's not so great
you can't see it i went to one of the
pilots i said how good is this plane
well it's really good
why is it good because the enemy can't
see it i said i don't know too much
about what you do
sounds good to me continuing that uh old
trope
and then a bizarre moment when
republican congressman mike kelly says
no flu is going to keep trump down
again rehabilitating this false notion
that coronavirus is the flu if this is
the time
this is your psalm oath to america
we're going to make america great again
again
because of donald j trump
there's no flu that's going to keep this
man down
he makes the energizer bunny look like a
deadhead
no flu keeping trump down but
952 americans
did die yesterday as we approach
spike number three of coronavirus
here's a completely incoherent thought
from donald trump
i can't even pretend to explain this one
to you
it's a verbal inkblot take a look you
have seen what's been going on how well
we're doing
did you see the recent poll just came
out
56 percent of the people want to be
here not four years ago they want to be
with us
in what we're calling we're rounding the
turn on the pandemic
56 and it's a record
epic job growth safe vaccines
that quickly end the pandemic it's
ending
normal life that's all we want you know
we want
normal life
just not making any sense and then trump
i guess wrapping up sort of early
yesterday because
it was cold in erie pennsylvania trump
sounding sedated by the end listen to
the slow motion version
of trump's now ubiquitous uh rally
closing
that i know you well a lot of time in
this
incredible land this beautiful place
this place of history
the incredible people of pennsylvania we
have
made america powerful again our military
never been like this
remember at the beginning when the
overrated general said to me
sir we have no ammunition i said no
president should ever have that
no president should ever hear those
words sir we have no ammunition
we now have so much ammunition that even
mike would be impressed
wrapping up there with a sort of sedated
sounding nod
to the military-industrial complex trump
tonight
in charlotte north carolina and then of
course tomorrow night
the second and what will be the final
presidential debate between joe biden
and donald trump i will be covering it
live on youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me at about half
past 8 p.m eastern time
and of course continued coverage clips
polling memes and other hijinks
on the david pakman show instagram at
david pakman show
again uh if you want to see me voting
very
strongly uh voting over the weekend
catch video of me voting on my instagram
page
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
our deep dive
into systemic racism coming up after the
break
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any
jittery feeling or a midday crash and
they have
over 20 000 five-star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this
video